j'ai décidé de me concentrer sur une seule chose.
Une chose dont je ne me passe pas :
mon café du matin.
Il s'est trouvé que ce n'était pas si simple que ça du tout.
(Rires)
Cette recherche a pris des mois.
Elle m'a emmené autour du monde.
Parce que j'ai découvert que mon café ne serait pas possible
sans des centaines de personnes que je prends pour acquises.
J'ai donc remercié le chauffeur routier
qui a transporté les grains de café au café.
Mais il n'aurait pas pu faire son travail sans la route.
J'ai donc remercié les personnes qui ont pavé la route.
(Rires)
J'ai ensuite remercié les personnes qui ont fait l'asphalte pour la chaussée.
Puis je me suis rendu compte que mon café,
comme tant d'autres choses dans le monde,
nécessite le travail associé
d'un nombre impressionnant de personnes provenant de tous les horizons.
Des architectes, des biologistes, des graphistes, des miniers, des bergers,
peu importe.
J'ai décidé d'appeler mon projet
« Merci mille fois. »
Parce qu'au final j'ai fini par remercier plus d'un millier de gens.
Et c’était éprouvant, mais aussi magnifique.
Parce que ça m'a permis de me concentrer
sur les centaines de choses qui se passent bien chaque jour,
plutôt que sur les deux ou trois choses qui se passent mal.
Et ça m'a rappelé les incroyables interconnexions de notre monde.
J'ai appris des dizaines de leçons pendant ce projet,
mais laissez-moi me concentrer sur cinq d'entre elles.
La première est : regardez.
J'ai commencé mon parcours de gratitude
en remerciant le serveur de mon café local.
Joe Coffee à New York.
Elle s'appelle Chung,
et Chung est l'une des personnes les plus optimistes que vous puissiez rencontrer.
Grand sourire, câline, enthousiaste.
Mais même pour Chung, être serveuse est difficile.
Et c'est parce que vous rencontrez des gens dans un état très dangereux.
(Rires)
Vous savez ce que c'est… la précaféination.
Chung a eu des personnes qui lui ont crié dessus jusqu’à ce qu'elle pleure,
y compris une fille de neuf ans,
qui n'aimait pas le dessin de crème fouettée
que Chung avait fait sur son chocolat chaud.
J'ai donc remercié Chung,
et elle m'a remercié de l'avoir remerciée.
Je me suis arrêté là.
Je ne voulais pas entrer dans une boucle infinie de remerciements.
(Rires)
Mais Chung a dit que la partie la plus difficile,
c'est quand les gens ne la traite même pas comme un être humain.
Ils la traitent comme un distributeur.
Donc, ils lui tendent leur carte de crédit
sans même lever les yeux de leur téléphone.
Alors qu'elle raconte ça, je me rends compte que je l'ai déjà fait.
J'ai été un vrai con.
Et à ce moment-là, j'ai promis :
que lorsque je serai avec des gens, je prendrai deux secondes
pour les regarder, établir un contact visuel.
Parce que ça vous rappelle que vous êtes avec un être humain
qui a une famille, des aspirations
et des souvenirs d'école honteux.
Et ce petit moment de connexion
est si important pour l'humanité et le bonheur des deux personnes.
Bon, la deuxième leçon, c’était :
sentez les roses. Et la terre. Et l'engrais.
Après Chung, j'ai remercié cet homme.
C'est Ed Kaufmann.
Ed est celui qui choisit quel café est servi dans mon café local.
Il voyage autour du monde, de l'Amérique du Sud à l'Afrique,
pour trouver les meilleurs cafés.
J'ai donc remercié Ed.
Et en retour, Ed m'a montré comment goûter le café comme un pro.
Et c'est tout un rituel.
Vous plongez votre cuillère dans le café,
puis, vous prenez une grosse et bruyante gorgée.
D'une manière presque caricaturale.
Afin de pulvériser le café dans toute votre bouche.
Vous avez des papilles gustatives à l'intérieur de vos joues,
sur le palais,
il faut toutes les atteindre.
Donc Ed faisait cela
et il...
son visage s'illuminait et il disait :
« Ce café a un goût de pomme Honeycrisp
avec des notes de terre et de sirop d'érable. »
Et je buvais une gorgée et je disais :
« Je pense que c'est du café.
(Rires)
Pour moi, ça a le goût du café. »
Mais inspiré par Ed, j'ai décidé de vraiment
laisser le café reposer sur ma langue pendant cinq secondes,
on est tous occupé, mais j'avais bien cinq secondes,
et penser à la texture, à l’acidité et au sucré.
J'ai commencé à le faire avec d'autres aliments.
Et cette idée de savourer est tellement importante pour la gratitude.
Les psychologues expliquent que la gratitude
consiste à prendre un instant et à s'y accrocher le plus longtemps possible.
Et aussi à ralentir le temps.
Pour que la vie ne passe pas en un instant, comme c'est souvent le cas.
La troisième est :
trouvez les chefs-d'œuvre cachés qui vous entourent.
L'une de mes conversations préférées cette année
a été avec le type qui a inventé le couvercle de ma tasse.
Et jusqu’à ce moment,
je n'avais jamais pensé aux couvercles de tasses.
Mais j'ai adoré parlé avec cet inventeur, Doug Fleming,
parce qu'il est tellement passionné.
Et tout le sang, la sueur et les larmes qu'il a mis dans ce couvercle
dont je n'avais jamais tenu compte.
Il dit qu'un mauvais couvercle peut gâcher votre café.
Qu'il peut bloquer l'arôme,
si important pour l'expérience.
Il est donc très innovant.
Il est le Elon Musk des couvercles à café.
(Rires)
Il a donc dessiné ce couvercle composé d'un hexagone inversé
pour que vous puissiez y mettre votre nez et obtenir un maximum d'arôme.
C'était un plaisir de lui parler
et il m'a fait réaliser qu'il y a des centaines de chefs-d'œuvre autour de nous
que nous prenons pour acquis.
Comme l'interrupteur de ma lampe de bureau qui possède un petit espace pour mon pouce
qui correspond exactement à mon pouce.
Et quand quelque chose est bien fait,
le processus derrière est complètement invisible.
Mais en y prêtant attention,
nous pouvons puiser dans ce sentiment d'émerveillement et enrichir nos vies.
Quatrièmement : faites semblant jusqu'à ce que vous le ressentiez.
A la fin du projet, j'étais dans une telle frénésie de remerciements.
Donc, j'étais... Je me levais et passais des heures,
J’écrivais des emails, j'envoyais des mots,
je passais des coups de fil, je visitais des gens
pour les remercier de leur rôle dans mon café.
Et certains, très franchement,
ne comprenaient pas vraiment.
Ils disaient des choses comme : « C'est quoi ça ?
Est-ce un système pyramidal, que voulez-vous, que vendez-vous ? »
Mais la plupart des gens ont été étonnamment touchés.
Je me souviens, j'ai appelé la femme qui réalise la lutte antiparasitaire
de l'entrepôt où mon café est servi -
pardon - là où mon café est stocké.
Et j'ai dit :
« Ça peut vous paraître bizarre,
mais je veux vous remercier d'éloigner les insectes de mon café. »
Et elle a dit : « Eh bien, je trouve ça bizarre,
mais vous avez égayé ma journée. »
Et ça n'a pas été un appel inutile.
Il n'y a pas qu'elle qui a été touchée, moi aussi.
Parce que je me réveillais chaque matin
de mon humeur habituelle, c'est-à-dire mauvaise,
mais je me forçais à écrire une note de remerciement
puis une autre et encore une autre.
Ce que j'ai remarqué, c'est qu'en agissant comme si vous étiez reconnaissant,
vous devenez vraiment reconnaissant.
La puissance de nos actions pour changer notre esprit est étonnante.
Souvent, nous pensons que les pensées changent le comportement,
mais le comportement très souvent change nos pensées.
Enfin, la dernière leçon dont je veux vous parler est :
pratiquez six niveaux de gratitude.
Et chaque endroit, chaque arrêt sur ce parcours de la gratitude
donnera naissance à 100 autres personnes que je pourrais remercier.
En Colombie, je suis allé remercier les fermiers qui cultivent mes grains de café.
C'était dans une petite ville de montagne,
j'ai été conduit là-bas le long de ces routes sinueuses et escarpées.
Et à chaque virage en épingle à cheveux,
le chauffeur faisait le signe de croix.
Et je me disais : « Merci pour ça.
(Rires)
Mais pouvez-vous le faire tout en gardant vos mains sur le volant ?
Parce que je suis terrifié. »
Mais on a survécu.
Et j'ai rencontré les fermiers, les frères Guarnizo.
C'est une petite ferme, ils font du très bon café,
ils sont payés au-dessus des prix du commerce équitable pour ça.
Et ils m'ont montré comment le café pousse.
La fève est à l'intérieur du fruit, appelé la cerise de café.
Et je les ai remerciés.
Et ils ont dit : « Eh bien, nous ne pourrions pas faire notre travail
sans une centaine d'autres personnes. »
La machine qui dépulpe le fruit est fabriquée au Brésil,
et le camion qu'ils utilisent dans la ferme,
est composé de pièces venant du monde entier.
En fait, les USA exportent de l'acier en Colombie.
Donc, je suis allé en Indiana et j'ai remercié les fabricants d'acier.
Ça m'a fait comprendre
qu'un village ne suffit pas à préparer une tasse de café.
Il faut le monde pour préparer une tasse de café.
Et cette économie mondiale, cette mondialisation,
elle a ses inconvénients.
Mais je crois que les avantages sur le long terme sont bien plus grands,
que le progrès est réel.
Nous nous sommes améliorés ces 50 dernières années,
la pauvreté dans le monde a baissé.
Nous devrions résister à la tentation
de nous retirer dans nos silos.
Et nous devrions résister à cette recrudescence
d'isolationnisme et de chauvinisme.
Ce qui m'amène à mon dernier point.
Mon espoir est que nous utilisions la gratitude comme moyen d'agir.
Certains s'inquiètent d'un mauvais côté à la gratitude.
Que nous serons si reconnaissants que nous serons complaisants.
Nous serons si « Oh, tout est merveilleux, je suis si reconnaissant. »
Eh bien, il se trouve que l'inverse est vrai.
Les recherches montrent
que plus vous êtes reconnaissant, plus vous avez de chances d'aider les autres.
Quand vous êtes dans un mauvais état,
vous êtes souvent plus concentré sur vos propres besoins.
Mais la gratitude vous pousse à donner au suivant.
Je l'ai expérimenté personnellement.
Je ne suis pas Mère Thérésa,
je suis toujours un salaud d'égoïste la plupart du temps.
Mais, je suis meilleur qu'avant ce projet.
Et c'est parce que j'ai pris conscience
de l'exploitation de la chaîne d'approvisionnement.
Ça m'a rappelé que ce que je prends pour acquis
n'est pas disponible pour des millions de gens à travers le monde.
Comme l'eau.
Le café est composé à 98,8 % d'eau.
Je devrais aller remercier les gens du réservoir de New York -
ils sont des centaines - qui me fournissent de l'eau,
et le miracle de pouvoir tourner le robinet et avoir de l'eau potable.
Et que des millions de personnes dans le monde n'ont pas ce luxe
et doivent marcher des heures pour avoir de l'eau potable.
Ça m'a inspiré de voir ce que je pourrais faire
pour aider les gens à avoir plus d'accès.
J'ai fait des recherches et j'ai trouvé un excellent groupe
qui s'appelle les « Dispensers for Safe Water ».
Et je me suis impliqué.
Je ne m'attends pas à ce que le comité du Prix Nobel
frappe à ma porte,
mais c'est un petit pas, un petit quelque chose.
Et tout cela par gratitude.
C'est pourquoi j'encourage les gens, les amis, la famille,
à suivre leur propre chemin de gratitude.
Parce que c'est une expérience qui transforme la vie.
Pas forcément à partir du café.
Ça peut être n'importe quoi.
Ça pourrait être une paire de chaussettes, une ampoule.
Pas besoin de faire le tour du monde, vous pouvez juste faire un petit geste
comme établir un contact visuel ou
envoyer un mot au dessinateur d'un logo que vous aimez.
Il s'agit plus d'un état d'esprit.
Être conscient des milliers de gens impliqués dans chaque petite chose
que nous faisons.
Se souvenir qu'il y a quelqu'un dans une usine
qui a fait les tissus pour les chaises sur lesquelles vous êtes assis maintenant.
Que quelqu’un est allé dans une mine et a extrait le cuivre pour ce micro
afin que je puisse dire un dernier merci
qui est de vous remercier.
Merci mille fois pour avoir écouté mon histoire.
(Applaudissements)
(Acclamations)